welcome Skylar Grey is here we were just
talking about Ken bone you don't know
ken bone is you missed it happen did you
watch the debate at all oh I try to stay
away yeah
he's the big fat guy with the red
sweater and the mustache that asked a
question the Internet's become obsessed
with him yeah but you see the problem
you will you should check it out and
you're a good person to talk to about
this because I think his uh his internet
fame that he's got now I think he's
letting it go to his head a little bit
and I think it's gonna be harsh when it
comes crashing down do you know what I
mean yeah don't is does that happen did
you have to deal with any of that cuz
you got signed no to amuse not you I
didn't have to deal with that because
nothing for me happened overnight right
but for people that that you know Fame
happens overnight it's very scary it is
right how many years gonna take you well
I don't even think I'm famous so naive
you are
yeah I've been doing music since I was
six years old so yeah it's been a long
time but you got signed to a deal when I
was like 17 or 18 so 30 now yeah when
you get signed when you're 17 or 18 are
you like this is it like did you think
that that would be the moment did you
think the overnight Fame was coming uh I
guess kind of yeah I didn't really know
what a record deal was when I got one I
was like shocked by it I didn't really
know what to expect
yeah um but yeah I mean I guess I
thought that when I had a record deal
that my life would just change
completely in great and everybody would
just work hard for me and I would just
be able to relax and write songs and
that was it but then I realized that um
I shouldn't have thought about it like
that and when you get signed it's like
the day you have to start working harder
really it's not like this team forms
around you and I mean they do but like
you have to lead the pack and like you
know work together and do a lot of work
yourself did you have complete control
over do they start taking control back
um younger I had less control cuz you
know I was like 18 year old from
Wisconsin with no business experience
and I wouldn't trust me either
but now at this point second record deal
I've learned a lot of hard lessons and
I'm applying all that to what I'm doing
now so yeah we had how the first one did
what that were you happy with had the
first one did the first album Oh back in
the day so that was 2006 I've released
an album called
like blood like honey and it was a under
my name Holly Brook and no it didn't do
very well so you were yeah and then it
was cut partially my fault
just being green and stuff and then I
lost that record deal and then I got a
new one and then I put out an album with
that a couple three years ago with
Interscope and that was um under the
name Skylar Grey yes I go by now and
then I just released my new album
natural causes like a few weeks ago why
did you change your name um because I
had a got a second chance in the music
industry and I just felt like I needed
to reinvent and give it a different
label so when you were when you were
younger and you were you hadn't really
figured everything out and you were
thinking people would be doing things
for you and it just wasn't happening
yeah did you kind of get pushed out at
the industry and have to come back in
yeah what happened well pushed out
slowly
um people started expressing to me that
they didn't want to work together
anymore
I know my manager my lawyer no it's just
I wasn't making anybody any money how'd
you manage it manager what are they what
he do calling all this is not working
yeah terrible it no it wasn't just like
it's there's a lot more layers than that
um I was kind of like talking to some
other people cuz I didn't think he was
doing his job right you know I'm like
why why am I not making money it's your
fault you know what I mean I was like
trying to point fingers and so um I was
talking to some other managers and he
found out so he got he was like okay bye
yeah I guess yeah yeah cuz I was like
you know interested to hear what
somebody else would do for me because I
was like maybe he's he's dropping the
ball you know yeah well he should have
just said no look here's what I'm doing
for you if he believed in you he would
have said that so you got lucky by him
dropping out yeah I know it ended up
good and I love him actually he's and
Alton he's like
great guy it was a kind of messy end but
we're good now we're friends again yeah
every relationship they always and like
[ __ ] there's a lot of bad blood and then
eventually talk yeah when you see young
people now because you do a lot of song
writing like you do a lot in the music
industry so when young people are coming
in like do you take on kind of like
mentor role or do you just step back and
be like I don't need to get involved
anybody else right now um if they ask
for advice or help then I'm willing to
give it but I don't offer it unless I
specifically ask I guess there's nothing
worse than somebody coming up being like
kid let me tell you how it's done yeah I
want to preach or anything Plus
everybody story's different why should I
want to help your competition I know
when people tell me like what do I do is
a young comedian I'm like always just do
dramatic things funny you don't help the
up-and-comer no I'm like spit in the
Booker's face show who's boss
never doing good advice come all the
wrong clubs to go to yeah it's bad I do
do stuff like talk at schools and stuff
though you do yeah like I've talked it
um with Berkeley and you know just like
other music schools and I do like um I
give advice at those places just giving
like any set is the point of the talks
giving people more familiarity with the
music industry yeah just you know
telling my story yeah you know hopefully
they get something good out of it
so Holly Brookes your real name er was
that Oh Brooke is my middle name
my last name's hofferman and that's just
not a stage not opening yeah new music
from Holly Harper merely Holly Hoffman's
a nice name I think I said he's name we
got the new single from Holly Harper man
exactly you see why I didn't use that
yeah I guess I went by Holly Brook for a
while but then um yeah I had like this
whole you know I lost my record deal
that whole thing I had a whole life
before Skylar Grey in the industry so
when I came back I was like I'm gonna
call this something else it's a
different project I'm approaching it
totally differently creatively and all
that so you think Skylar Grey sounds
cooler than Holly Harmon well I wanted
to just be gray right yeah Gray's my
favorite color and it's like a very it
represents a lot what shade of gray do
you like the best
well all of them oh I'm a battleship
gray person that's you I like I like a
heather gray I've never heard of I like
I don't like a fog like gray skies yeah
whatever that is and it's kind of a
mixture of a lot of different grazing
and how Schuyler was a kind like a sky
thing yeah yeah cuz you like gray yes
guy and walk so when I when I quit the
industry for that time period I lived in
a cabin in the woods in Oregon by myself
and it was like super quite a shell time
yeah why I took her Unabomber no I did
actually Ted Kaczynski was the more
owner had some really unhealthy thoughts
out there no I'm kidding how long were
you alone to wish for um pretty solid
for like four months
Jesus and then I and then I went back
and forth between there no I was at
first for the first two weeks I was kind
of nervous because there's a lot of
mountain lions um and so I had to walk
to my cabin I'm like it was not um on a
road right so where'd you find the cabin
uh it was like my mom's friend had this
property that she bought after her
husband died of a brain tumor and she
won like a lawsuit of malpractice or
something and bought like this huge
piece of property and there's like just
little building scattered on it and
always like let me use one of the one of
the buildings so it was a blessing was
awesome much being lost in the woods and
you finally come up on a cabin and
Skyler Drazen and like well there's a
blonde in the middle the woods amazing
awesome thing was a setup was a TV show
IDs the bathroom and it was really
rustic yeah it's fun though super rustic
but you just pissed in the woods no
there was a bathroom but it was like
outside I had to it yeah
Oh used an outhouse for four months no I
mean it was it was like an outhouse but
it had a flush it was a real toilet but
not attack but it was not attached and
so like in the middle of the night you
get up and you have to go and you go
outside okay listen did you have a
coffee can and for those nights when it
was raining yes I did not a happy we
don't like knock bucket or something did
you yeah I know and you just yeah and
dump it out the next day but if you had
to go number two then you have no choice
oh I said that's what you meant no no
Kevin Jim wants no get any of the coffee
cans left
yeah yeah no no not for dirty purposes I
just display them on my mantle yeah
celebrity memorabilia yeah yeah I have a
Gaga log from he was looking for for
some Skyler wood chips that's it yeah I
told him it was inappropriate but I I
admire the fact that you willing to do
that like I'm such I'm so weird like I
literally have to be in a hotel or my
own house I can't I can't live rustic
like you do it you would freak out for
the first two weeks and then you would
feel like a resident of the woods and I
started talking to myself out there and
like talking to the animals and the
trees and it was really we had a
relationship at the time um oh that
would know cuz this when I lost my
record deal I also lost my relationship
it all just like you know when it rains
it pours right you're loaded I thought
you know I might as well die or goes
live in a cabin in the woods and
challenge myself to see if I can survive
that did you dump them or do they dump
because you lost your record deal I
wasn't worried had nothing to do that
okay there's just everything it had at
the same time and it was awful
but then I wrote a song called love the
way you lie Ryan my whole life did a 180
so so let me ask you so you write this
song you didn't write that in the woods
yeah you wrote it in the woods yeah
that's probably why you went there to
clear your head and get a little things
like I have no never
you're an artist Jimmy you understand
right I saw her he decide he thinks
would you goes did you pick leaves I
understand what the words are about
you're so right when I went there I
didn't think hey it leaves for the
record but pick delete yeah I didn't
think any he's dumb
I I know I know no I went there to find
myself because I was the head writers
black really bad and so I went there to
like reconnect with my passion for music
and life and whatever figure out who I
wanted to be and the first song that
came out of that was love the way you
lie
so when love the way you lie becomes
this like monster hit are you like oh
[ __ ] I wish I had sang it like that
always and always I always wonder about
that with songwriters no because I show
you there's not a better like rihanna
and eminem are like the biggest two
biggest you know artists in the world
and that's probably why the song
so much attention in the first place was
because it's like oh my gosh nobody ever
imagined that he would do a song with
Rihanna I think it was like a surprise
like wow this is crazy
and so the second his album came out
that song jumped to number one like
instantly yes on iTunes people are
freaking out I don't think that would
happen if it was me singing it so what's
the industry finds out about that song
are you then like a songwriter in demand
yes because it's like she wrote a single
she can write everybody was calling me I
want and love the way you lie part 9
yeah yeah that's great like uh it was a
lot of pressure though because I people
wanted me to deliver a hit every time
right it doesn't work like that oh we're
trying to keep things that like we're
kind of similar to that like do we try
to connect I used to love the way you
lie but now I hate the way yeah yeah I
hate the way you're truth it's just not
the same thing that's not what I see
okay oh it's hard to write for other
people like I hate writing for other
people I only like to a I don't want to
give away anything good and B I just I'm
afraid that I'm not going to be able to
to speak in their voice I don't know how
people write for other people it's hard
to do plus I get mad at you and nobody
laughs at the jokes I mean that's the
most obvious point that kind of goes
without saying I write real like I said
really bad jokes on purpose hopefully
they do it bomb but when I write a song
I always think of it as a song for
myself even if I'm writing it for
somebody okay and then sometimes it
works for somebody else do you write
better when you're miserable I I can't
really write as much stuff when I'm
happy
it usually comes out of be feeling
shitty so do you write better stuff any
feeling shitty yeah well not what I'm
feeling shitty but like after feeling
shitty um reflecting on reflecting on
yeah you can't be in the middle insight
is 20/20 yeah and if I'm in the middle
of it I'm it's too confusing I don't
know what's going on do you talk ideas
into like your Siri or something like I
this would be a good idea for a song or
do you actually just sit down with paper
okay here it's time to write it it's
different every time but I do keep a
little notepad of ideas you know in my
phone but most of the time I just feel
it I start with the music and then
lyrics kind of just flow were you
writing songs for other people before
love the way you lie and all this
started no so at what did you were you
worried at all that you were gonna be
like I don't want to just be considered
a songwriter like I want to be a singer
I want to be a star I want to
or are you just so happy you know weird
it was like a um yeah I wasn't expecting
that career out being a songwriter for
other people but I embraced it and now
it's paying my bills so I'm not mad at
it there's that's where a lot of the
money is yeah all right say in the
songwriting yeah whoo you wrote it did
you how did they get their hands on it
did you say like okay this is for you
too or did you write it and someone
Interscope what you know I think he
should do this well at the time I wasn't
signed or anything and I had just met
the producer of the song I met him over
email and so because there was an
internet cafe in the or not in the woods
but by the woods that I would drive to
and so um I wrote that stuff that hook
sent it to him he was in New York and
then sent somehow he got it to Eminem
and then Eminem did his part and then
Rihanna recorded her part in Dublin and
the whole song was created with people
that were never in the same room
together we'd never met each other in
person before
none of us which is so crazy technology
have you met them since yes okay yeah
we've heard we performed on the Grammys
together what was that what is it like I
was I was wonder about that cuz you've
had a lot of high profile performances
you did like he did the Grammys like you
said you've done WrestleMania with P
Diddy yeah that's so weird it's weird
right a wrestling fan uh I kind of
now-now you're all right you know she is
kind of kind of a joke though yeah like
not really ironic ly yeah totally I get
I get where this is stupid
yeah yeah yeah but I get like the best
seats in the house and right fun like to
just like get really amped up about it
probably makes like a lot of like real
wrestling fans like very upset cuz
you're like well I'm just here because I
think it's stupid but fun and they're
like well we would love to have your
seat you know maybe I shouldn't have
admitted that the resting watch won't
pick that up to limber notice um but I
performed it at WrestleMania three times
and where I'm like why do you guys keep
calling me back yeah would inform in the
ring no um I brought a John Cena and the
rock out one one time so it was like
that stage where they had like the
fireworks right okay
Jim went to a Wrestlemania one year but
he didn't stay for John Cena in the rock
because he wanted to beat the traffic
yeah so I decided to leave early before
I Myra I wanted to see the vintage so
many wrestlers I used to I don't really
watch it but I wanted to see what they
did like so those those guys so much
it was fun to watch right but it was
chilly without doors in giant Stadium
remember how about August Vince didn't
work or whatever it was but it was a
parolee I was a little chilly
it was nippy yeah and you were you part
of the mad rush to exit the stadium
no I didn't I wish hold we relaxed it's
a nice walks just to you there's no one
no one I couldn't find my car was in
safe course it's so happy to miss it but
what's it like to perform with like I
guess with P Diddy to start with like
when you're is it is it tough does he
have a certain way of doing things I do
have to be like okay whatever you want
like what is that like is he a
perfectionist well it's kind of a funny
story actually we were doing sound check
for that performance and um I was asking
for things in my ear my monitors like
more bass like because I need certain
things to be able to sing and he would
just be like yeah me too
I'd like to see that nobody wants in his
ears like does he not know what you know
yes I carry
he just wants whatever the singers go
you get offstage and he's like how do
you know what to ask for
really so I don't know everybody's
different to perform with he's so fun
yes yeah yeah yeah it's so much fun yeah
that's funny laughs 11 yeah good for him
to admit that the PJ is like I don't
know what joins everybody just inherited
spot it was so pretty when you put your
headphones on video that's where those
go no it was so sweet yeah he's super
nice I love him but no part of you was
like he's sold like millions of records
and he doesn't even know how to monitor
music at all oh no I mean I don't think
that's the case it was just I don't know
yeah it's just weird
what about Eminem how is he how is he to
perform with and kind of work with he's
awesome Daisy in a totally different way
yeah yeah how is he in a different way
he's like he's a perfectionist
yes yeah oh he knows what he wants yeah
for sure he knows what to ask for in his
in his ear
yeah which is easier for you though
because if someone is telling you
exactly what they want you don't have to
wonder there's no vagueness to it you
kind of know this is how it's gonna be
done yeah you know he's really great to
work with I've learned so much working
with him for sure you have yeah for sure
what difference is it when you like at
this point in your career now that
you've kind of experienced everything
you've taken all these weird turns and
you figured out that like I'm assuming
you've figured out that maybe your plan
isn't necessarily what's going to pan
out you just kind of have to go with
what happens like what is it like are
you chasing Fame now at all is there do
you look at success differently
totally totally look at it differently
when I was a kid I was super ambitious
and like you know thought if I had money
and success and fame and whatever I
would be happy but I feel like every
time I have those little fleeting
moments of success its fleeting it just
sits there one day of really high and
then you get rejected the next day and
it sucks and so I realized that I
couldn't base my happiness on any of
that stuff and that's one of the reasons
I live in Utah in the mountains because
I just like to you know enjoy every day
of my life see a beautiful mountain view
hang out with my dog like that to me is
the key to Hatchin you retreat being
yeah yeah yeah I'm just like enjoying a
moment and finding the beauty in every
moment I feel like that's that's what
happiness is about and then if you get
successful along the way that's cool
that's awesome but like I don't base my
yeah your other side ya know if you talk
I've been to Utah it's eivin's I've
spent a decent amount of time there it
was more fun than I would have thought
even though it's very quiet just walking
around clean Park City I'm Salt Lake
okay so I think that's the only place to
eat I've been to a few times but it's
beautiful and it's nice to be I don't
like it live there though yeah - quiet
yeah well I live in Park City which is
only 7,500 people Wow oh yeah one more
time Sully you like your solitude yeah
for sure but don't people know that
you're there then like aren't you the
famous person who lives in Salt Lake
well no there's a ton of like way more
successful people than me living in that
my area where people go to retreat kind
of like the Beverly Hills of Utah I got
you a Alpine New Jersey yeah what I did
yeah I did have a stalker come knock on
my door one time really yeah and then
that made
you know local radio and news like but
you stalk her a fan
I mean well once you follow you home and
knocks on your door but yeah it's weird
when you come to my house yeah and it's
a gated community and you walk in
because you know you can't drive in and
so you like hiked on trails to get to my
house longer territory he did it twice
that's a shocker so the first time it
happened it was just weird we sent him
away the second time was a month later
and he drove all the way from Wisconsin
so I went to Utah to realize the bullets
no I was at home with my husband but the
second time it happened it was 3:00 a.m.
and my husband was asleep so I was just
like up working in the house and then I
got this text from somebody who keeps an
eye on my social media and he was like
hey you better watch out I think your
stalkers in your neighborhood and sure
enough he was like we because he had
tweeted something like about being there
and so we got up and got all the cops
like they were all eating Donuts at the
7-eleven down the street and I was like
hey my stalkers in the neighborhood they
put their search lights all over the
hills they found them like on foot again
walking to my house that's [ __ ]
creepy had a husband react that's a
happy why's the target of somebody who's
trying to talk to or whatever's got like
a murderous yeah yeah he probably freaks
out more than I do actually sure yeah
yeah we have some guns though and oh
good we're and security cameras and
alarms so you're right enough
what is he I'm pretty prepared what
what's your husband do he's my manager
oh okay so he understands everything
back oh yes all right that's really good
so what happened the stalker the second
time the cops are would they arrested
him for what um well so it's a kind of a
long story but it basically he tried
again then the same night to get back to
my home
touch man so it was the third time that
they they arrested him what does he
thinks gonna happen like what are
stalkers think they think oh but I was
gonna say is um like you keep the first
time it happens you can't do anything
sure it's like the second or third time
when they like repeat offenses then you
can arrest them right because it looks
like they didn't have anything on him
they like searched his car try to find
drugs like try to find something to like
pin him for and they couldn't the first
time you know
so they had to wait for him to do it
husband probably hopes that he gets into
the house so he can shoot him I can then
be done with I don't think I don't think
my husband ever game that's always dance
Sam just always wants to shoot people
probably be the one to shoot somebody
but I don't understand men's mentality
or people's mentality to show up at
someone's house what the [ __ ] do you
thinks gonna happen it's so deranged
like you got to be off somewhere so far
wrong I think we found out that he might
be schizophrenic cuz he was talking to
voices in his head that said I wanted
him to be there and like all that stuff
boys what do you think it like you're
gonna open the door 3:00 in the morning
go hi what's your name huh you're kinda
cute come on it we go out how does that
work out oh good the voice has got to
yeah yeah I was hoping you'd come back
sending you messages telepathy
yeah that's an illness is one thing but
you know what a the person knew enough
to park outside the gated community just
drive through the gate he's not that
crazy yeah that's the thing and that's
why the judge let him go after like two
they kept him in jail for like two weeks
and they were like we can't keep you
here anymore if you were competent
enough to make it out from Wisconsin to
find her house you get here then like
you should be able to survive outside of
these bars or you know but his mom cuz
the kid was like 21 and his mom didn't
want him to get out of jail she leave
him in there I can't handle him anymore
just lock him up and I won't have to
worry about him at all what she's
probably just tired of him playing your
records really loud records how old am I
an old man reference what the turntable
I know worse how are you married for
Lombard not you huh Oh Jim gets
confession remember and you can't
remember so you need romantic one and
Jesus no she wants to do the shooting
and I don't know ask him yeah yeah while
I don't know look at see my ring is even
like a gangster ring it's literally wow
it's a nice dream it's it's a tissue box
sighs ring yeah with diamonds on it Wow
so you must have been really happy to
get a new manager I guess since you
yeah worked out well for you yeah he was
my boyfriend or whatever before he was
my manager and you're like fighting with
us doing well cuz I knew that he would
have the most like vested interest and
care at the most you know isn't weird
though like he's like Ozzy and Sharon
they
there's you're constantly intertwine
yeah it's a lot right yeah I don't think
it would work from a lot of people you
get sick of each other like if you're
fighting if you see arguing about
something in personal life and then you
go to the business like alright we got
to talk about this this gig how do you
separate them mmm
it kind of all blends together but we
don't really argue that's good yeah I've
never been in one like that ya know a
relationship that wasn't volatile it
must be so nice you're very highly
strung person is the thing yeah you know
I because I'm difficult right and I
track crazy people right and you love
him you love crazy people that's the
problem
I don't cuz saying people Google me like
no creep that's kind of all of theirs
but well listen everybody Skylar Grey's
new album is out now it's called natural
causes you can tweet her at Skylar Grey
s Kyl a are gray so if you're going to
be in her neighborhood and you think she
wants you to stop by make sure you tweet
before you come yeah yeah you'll have a
whole welcome party there for ya Zak
stop over and have a bullet sandwich
great now people are gonna know that
like we look at that stuff and so if
there are stalkers coming they're not
going to tweet and then there's still
cameras here there's still cameras in
the neighborhood and you know it's a
gated community it's obviously not that
easy to get in yeah well get the album
natural causes and Skylar thank you so
much for hanging out in queue that was
fun